here's our one token crypto question
from patrick
if you were interested investing in
crypto but wary of the coming
regulations from the us and abroad
uh good is paying attention there's a
lot of regulation what would you do is
it still worth investing in bitcoin and
ethereum or have i missed the boat
should i look into altcoins that have
much lower entry prices oh my lord
oh i mean look i'm going to give it i'm
going to say something that's going to
piss off all the crypto bros and they're
going to come chase after me like they
always do here out mention this trigger
warning guys you should turn off the
stream because you're gonna get mad at
me we got laser eyes you're all
so dead like basically my thesis and
i've been wrong since crypto like i
looked at it when it was like 55 cents
so at this point i'm like 100 000 x
wrong so like don't believe the word i
say but
here's why you're dead
so
i believe that the chinese government is
going to roll out a centralized digital
they have right now but they're going to
really roll out a centralized digital
coin that works just like bitcoin so
basically you have a secret key and
basically you have a public key and
you're going to be able to move money
around using like the same innovations
that are in the entire crypto ecosystem
but instead of being distributed they're
going to centralize it and from from a
from a strategic perspective it's like
unbelievably powerful because they're
going to say hey you know how the us
dollar has all these kycs and
regulations and you have to go through
all these banks not if you want to
basically use our coin you can do
whatever the hell you want it's got to
go through our database though so we get
to see everything but if you're a drug
dealer you want to move somebody around
we don't care and so then you can
imagine a world where remittances and
global money movement across a single
managed coin that is going to hold its
value and isn't going to fluctuate up
and down and isn't being manipulated by
a bunch of people like tether is
suddenly a superpower and the chinese
government is in a position to basically
like become the next global reserve
currency because they will just everyone
will use their currency at which point
the us government slowly and stupidly
will do the same thing at which point
crypto as this sort of like
decentralized libertarian wet dream
suddenly becomes a very very small part
of the global currency movements so it's
the old sort of microsoft world they're
going to embrace your innovations
they're going to extend their
capabilities using your innovations and
then they are going to extinguish you
the lovely crypto people it's the long
hug it's a long hug of it's an embracing
long hug we love your innovations and
now we will like a boa constrictor take
the life out of you every breath is
gonna be your demise i mean it really is
a sinister plan and the and i think
actually probably the most likely plan
they kicked out if you just look at
their behavior yeah i always say like
just look at the behavior they
kicked out all of this uh all the
bitcoin mining they made bitcoin illegal
they're tightening everything up they
experimented with their digital one um
and there's your mmb whatever it is and
there if your premise is perfect which
is hey
we don't care if you're funding terror
we don't care what you're doing we just
want to be the global supply yeah then
oh yeah by the way you felt like you got
your money stolen yeah and you know
somebody in the chinese government yeah
we could reverse that transaction for
you because we control it right
centralized and not being able to
reverse things is a pretty cool feature
um
unless you're a powerful person and you
want it reversed and you got a you know
xi jinping will take your phone call now
you could flip those things it's a
really interesting point and then i
think everything goes in the united
states goes regulated the u.s reserve
currency comes out
and then they just say to
anybody who's doing anything in crypto
uh either use the united states dollars
anything else is going to have a 10 tax
on it coming in coming out of it selling
it trading it whatever they can pick
whatever tax they want they can pick
whatever
uh regulation they want and they will
strangle
anonymous
decentralized money if they want to
they'll they'll strangle it through
regulation and taxation doesn't mean it
goes away you can still use bittorrent
you can still i'm sure use you know
uh any of those peer-to-peer stealing
file networks whatever
but
why would you bother if you can use
spotify and netflix and disney and get
4k and not have to [ __ ] with that yep
and that's really i think the end game
here uh so i would i'm with zach i mean
why bother buying this stuff if you
really love crypto and you know the code
and you know the code base and you can
evaluate the technology and you want to
dabble in it
sure sure yeah sure
but i i don't think it's the casual
thing to invest in uh live from youtube
hoda asks hey jason have a question
about
some of the reasons you may find in due
diligence that makes you avoid investing
in a startup great question
we do serious diligence these days
i'll tell you some of the things that
are very quick uh for us if what the
founder told us in the meetings it match
what we find in diligence well that's
kind of lying or stretching the truth
we'll often have people tell us they
have one amount of revenue and then it's
not what we see
or was exaggerated in some way then if
we see accounting problems where they're
doing cash-based accounting instead of
accrual they don't have good books and
they don't have control over their books
that's a problem if they have lawsuits
pending and they haven't been able to
resolve them if they're major
that's could be problematic and then
most of all i think you know the number
one thing is we find problems on cap
tables and the problems could be
they gave 50 of the company to a
development shop over four iterations of
their product for 10 to 15 each time
because it was 250k worth of work and
they did it for free and then all of a
sudden you gave a million dollars of
your equity which was half the company
and now you lost control of your company
then nobody else can invest in it or you
have four founders all four got all 25
given to them day one and two of them
never worked at the company past month
one now i got half the cap tables dead
money so cap table problems are always
problematic
you really want to have good books great
accounting great ips assignment
everybody signed over their assignment
great vesting
really clean cap table vesting means all
the founders get their shares over four
years
as opposed to just getting them day one
and then somebody quits and they get all
their shares for free uh those are the
red flags that we see most often what do
you see zach
i think you just hit all the nails i
mean there's a lot more there's a lot of
stuff in
sort of like figuring out that you know
there's a legit business that operates
correctly that has real customers as
real revenue has real bank accounts it
has real legal documentation it has real
lawyers it's like all the stuff that
needs to be real but yeah i think you
you nailed it
one of the things that happens is when
we ask for diligence
in the cases where we don't need to do
diligence they give you a folder in 90
seconds after you email them hey we're
ready to go to diligence i go okay
here's the document library and they
just share it with us on google drive or
dropbox or whatever it is
and then when there's a problem they're
like what do you want to see
and we're like here's the list and
they're like oh
and then we don't hear from them again
like literally they'll be so embarrassed
that they they can't even get through
this list and it's like if you can't get
through this list
for a one million dollar investment what
do you think the 20 million dollar
investment is going to look like
you know they're they're going to be
getting up in your accounting
everyone knows zendesk is the go-to for
customer support but what you may not
know is that zendesk also offers a suite
of sales tools so sales teams like yours
can spend more time on what really
matters having better customer
conversations so they can close more
deals faster zendesk is offering this
suite of sales tools plus their industry
leading support software for free for
six months as part of the zendesk for
startups programs along with free access
to all of zendesk you'll also get access
to zendesk community of startup founders
and partners to help you better serve
your customers they'll even offer
dedicated onboarding guidance and
support to get you up and running in no
time steezy studio one of our watch
portfolio companies that sells consumer
sas products you know dance tutorials
they love zendesk and through the
combination of zendesk explorer and
their ticket tagging system steezy can
track which features their users are
most excited about and relay that info
to the product team for steezy zendesk
is more than a crm tool it creates a
positive relationship with members and
empowers them to contribute to cesi's
growth in return for some awesome dance
moves you can get six months of zendesk
for startups free at zendesk.com
twist to qualify for the program you
must have under 50 employees and have
raised venture funding at series a or
below and be a new zendesk customer so
it's pretty fair and check out zendesk's
new podcast sit down start up available
on all major podcasting platforms every
customer counts when you're a startup
especially now so start building the
best customer experiences with zendesk